عكس اللاعبين الاوروبيين الذين يصتحبون
زوجاتهم اثناء البطولات خطفت امهات لاعبي
كره القدم المغربي اسود الاطلس انظار
العالم في مدرجات المونديال واصبحنا كل
القصه بعد ما سطر اسود المغرب انتصارا
تاريخيا قادهم الى المربع الذهبي في
نهائيات كاس العالم وعندك كل انتصار كان
لافتا جدا للعدسات العالميه لجوء اللاعبين
اولا الى احضان امهاتهم هذه المشاهد وصفها
الناس على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ببر
الوالدين وتم تداولها على نطاقنها ساعه
مهاجم منتخب المغرب زكريا بوفال اختار فقط
امه لتنزل معه الى المستطيل الاخضر بعد ما
تحول الى مساحه الاحتفالات اسود الاطلس
بعد التاهل التاريخي الى نصف نهائي كاس
العالم اشرف حكيمي ايضا رقد الى والدته
بعد صفاره النهايه
باللي راسها ولم يكتفي هنا بل غرد بالصور
وكتب احبك يا امي هذه المشاهد المفعمه
بالرضا شاهدناها اكثر من مباراه مع مدرب
المنتخب المغربي وليد الركراكي الذي عانق
والدته بحراره في مدرجات احد ملاعب
نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]